I think the part of the acting process
that that scares me
is every time I get a new role every
single time and I think every actor
feels exactly the same because there's
that the exhilaration first of all you
think oh my gosh I've got an amazing
script wow I've been I've got this
incredible part how exciting and then
it's like ah how am I going to find them
how am I going to do this where is this
person perhaps this character won't come
to me like oh my gosh maybe I can't act
this time like I have that on every
single role that I do and I think if I
didn't then I wouldn't be choosing the
right roles because I won't be
challenging myself and I've spoken to so
many actors and they all feel the same
and I think actors should not feel
scared when fact the biskits I think
it's a good sign I really do and I think
the fear is a motivator and I also think
it's a challenge to learn to use fear
and to use it as something that's really
positive for you and that works for you
and that makes you better
I do consciously try and vary my roles
and also I get bored really easily so I
just feel like if I played one type of
role then I wouldn't want to play it
again because I'm constantly looking to
challenge myself and really scare myself
I want to do something that I didn't
think was possible but I didn't realize
I could find in myself so that's how I
choose roles I just choose on the basis
of what what moves me and what excites
me so I thinking in everyday life we get
stuck into playing one role so we see
ourselves and we say you know I'm shy or
I'm serious or I'm you know and it's not
until you get an opportunity that forces
you to come out of yourself that you
realize you're not those things at all
because we are all made up we're
multifaceted you know and we are capable
of anything
so you know you look at another human
being and you say all that person saved
someone from rescuers from a fire you
know building one finally jumped into
the fire and they rescued somebody and I
could never do anything like that
because I'm not brave enough but you
don't know until you get put in that
situation what you're capable of and
acting constantly forces you to step
into the shoes of someone that you
didn't
you'd ever be anything like and then you
discover actually I have a lot in common
with this person and actually I
discovered something amazing about
myself but I'm capable of all sorts of
things I never knew before like for
instance with me with Paulo and
moonlight you know I never thought I
would really understand what addiction
was all about and through exploring that
role I feel as though we are all
actually addicted to something on some
level and actually Paul at the distance
between myself and Paulo is far smaller
than I realized
to find paula was I mean it was really
difficult because I don't drink alcohol
I don't smoke and I you know I didn't
even like drink coffee and like a
complete and utter health nut so I was
really apprehensive about how I was
going to find this crack addict that is
ultimately you know the woman that I was
playing the mother part of things I
thought yeah I can do that but it was
the addiction really that was really and
really scared me and and how I really
did it was YouTube YouTube I just think
it's an incredible mine of information
you can find anything that you want
there and there are these amazing clips
of footage by people who go into like
crack dens with their camera phones and
they interview crack addicts and they're
going to all kinds of places that you
would never feel safe going to you know
yourself but they get in there and they
you know interview these people and it's
such an incredible insight there are
also fabulous documentaries about
addiction and about Miami in the 1980s
and a specific area of Liberty City you
can find all of that on YouTube and that
for me was just this mine of information
that I just fed on and and then the gaps
in the story I really filled in through
my imagination so often we see others
are so different from ourselves and what
I think acting forces you to do is
realize that actually we are all so
similar and we're all just playing roles
and if we just broke down all these like
social constructs that we attached to
ourselves and labels and all the labels
of society wants to attach to
that are us as well and we realized
we're really very similar against
beautiful and my mum's a writer and so
I've always grown up believing that the
written word it's like you know that's a
Bible it's the script you know so I
always I just use the Bible the script
and as the mine of information and I
just read it lots and lots of times to
find out like where the clues to what my
character is thinking and feeling
what's her backstory and and then once
you get all of that information then
there are going to be huge gaps that you
know there's going to be huge swathes of
her life that unexplored and unexplained
and that's when you have to do your
research and use your imagination but I
love that process I think it's an
incredible and privilege to be able to
create another human being and then once
I've done all that research and I've
gathered all gathered all the
information then I sit in a chair and I
imagine a situation exactly like this so
I imagine that someone is interviewing
me and they're asking me questions like
you know what was it like when you grew
up in such-and-such area you know how
did you feel about your father how did
you feel about your mother
what was your experience of school like
and I just answer those questions and as
I am speaking then the mannerisms of
that person come and their voice starts
to come as well and the more I do it the
more those things come to me so it's not
I think thought through in terms of like
I don't think like oh I'm going to use
my hands in this particular way is this
person or keep my head tilted to the
left and we know it's not a conscious
decision I think it should be something
that happens to you so that a character
once you've done your research you have
to do your research first but I think
you have to allow the unconscious
process to happen I love fantasy and
characters and because Pirates of the
Caribbean is this crazy larger-than-life
you know totally unreal world nobody
could say well a character wouldn't
behave like that or she wouldn't do that
you and say that you and behave in that
way it's absolutely in those fantasy
worlds you can do anything you know
you're totally free and so Tia Dalma was
a total creation of my imagination and I
loved the process of finding her and I
loved how liberated she was and how
playful she was
and yes it was that was fantastic for me
it was the first time that I had kind of
explored actually I'd done them I've
done white teeth before that as well so
I had done the Jamaican accent but I
don't know I just felt like I was
getting in touch with like some part of
my Jamaican roots by playing her as well
I think the key to working with other
actors is being vulnerable being willing
to be vulnerable and being completely
open being playful and yeah you have to
be willing to make a fool of yourself
ultimately you know because that's the
only way that you really learn to play
with your fellow actors as you should so
it's really important as well that other
actors make you feel safe and that you
make them feel faced as well because
it's a real relationship of trust
because you've got both got to expose
yourself when you're acting I mean you
absolutely have to believe you know in
them and their character because that's
how you're you know relating to them but
ultimately it's something deeper than
that even you know it's not just you're
not relating and anything you ever
relating to people just on the basis of
their character like it's a soul
exchange you know so it's something
deeper than that and it's something much
more intimate and vulnerable for
instance you know when not doing
moonlight and I met my eldest son who's
played by trivanti Rhodes 10 minutes
before we had a very emotional scene
where I had to tell him that I was sorry
for the pain that I caused him in his
life and I was sorry that I was such a
bad mother and that he shouldn't let
that go on and affect the rest of his
life and his heart shouldn't be black as
my heart was black by all the
experiences that I've had and it was a
really emotional scene and we'd only met
each other 10 minutes before and we both
had to just trust each other to just
dive in and and be willing to be like
really vulnerable and really exposed to
each other and basically open our hearts
to each other and I think that's you
know I think that's really brave and I
really admire that about acting that
people are constant
willing to go this is me you know and
not to hide behind anything I think you
definitely take away something new from
each project because each character is
forcing you to grow in a new way
I don't think that personally I don't
believe that characters are ever found
on the outside of themselves I think
that all things that are within you
anyway so it's an exploration journey to
find that within yourself and then to
bring it into the light but most of the
times you just don't know that those
people are within you and that's what's
so special about the journey and I think
that's what's so special about acting is
that by finding these different parts of
yourself you grow you become more whole
and I think you become more complete as
a person
[Music]